Chrome PDF viewer crashed while printing
a document oh wow what a great use of
ink don't that barely costs anything
anyway hello everyone my name is
PewDiePie subscribe if you haven't
already we're reviewing software
software Gordon you everything computers
gonna take over the planet well this
video might make you reconsider let's
just watch more failed to print document
printing is not supported on this
printer Wow
what does the printer dude this printer
cannot print but you can make phone
calls error could not copy files because
now there's one possible way to reply to
this okay that's a great reason to
anything could not do it why no why did
you not clean your room feeling no okay
that's good I'll try that one hey Google
guide me to the hospital is that the
right direction
oh it's Hospital thanks Google only 34
hours away I love these what if you went
all the way to hospital and there's no
actual hospital they're not CERN as well
is like is did I get it right
it's the sir destination the most screen
time the last seven days settings
hundred and seven hours incredible job
that reminds me actually when when you
were a kid and he would get a new phone
and there wasn't that much to do on
phones back in the day so you were just
trying find like every little thing
about the phone like going through the
settings is this relatable because I
used to do this that's why this person
had 107 hours
in settings Oh have you been playing
games no set things I just love the
settings I got a coupon code for 30% of
Bluetooth headphones that ended up being
ninety-eight percent off when I enter
the code Wow
ninety-eight percent free that said
almost a great price but down we go oh
my god cringe this is Apple software
everyone knows Apple users are for dingy
stinky brainers oh my god is it going
down
I mean to be fair oh yeah why would
anyone do this stop this is literally me
when my girlfriend can't decide and I
just like leave my wife I have wife
we are sorry your driver license was not
the probe dang it
but why reason for not being approved
your license was a problem yeah what I
don't understand it there's something
funny about the absolute thumb freakery
about this law my bank just called me
because you can give your accounts
nicknames to remember which saving
account is which okay that makes sense
I put an emoji in one of them and
apparently somehow broke their entire
Bank existed so I guess don't do that
excuse me sir can you stop putting
emojis I do this a lot actually it's
really funny to see especially when
there's text-to-speech and see what
they're gonna say when you have the
cowboy emoji cowboy hat smiling face guy
did my dog just discover teleportation
dog Oh tracker whistle nutmeg is now at
home wait what
so this is an app that tracks your dog
and it and an app is called whistle and
the dog is called nutmeg got it okay
whistle nutmeg is now at home whistle
nutmeg is now at home
whistle heads-up nutmeg is 292 miles
from home near 270 over the street one
minute later whistle nutmeg is now at
home Wow damn no way this is like Toy
Story you know when you're not looking
they're toys same with dogs when you're
not looking they be teleporting what if
dogs have like many different owners
that they're trying to appease at all
time oh my god we don't deserve dogs
this is so nice
reasons you should keep us around okay
this is McAfee the most annoying
antivirus software that is useless
everyone had it back in the day because
there was no other software McAfee maybe
you should keep us around here's why
Oh God Oh God hmm you convinced me I'll
keep my web protection thank you very
much McAfee you convinced me with your
sound argument
as my friends shouldn't leave me here's
why give it a thigh let me know what you
think I movies expand title reflect oh
god I'm a visitor stop stop another
apple dump free curry software ok I'm
telling you guys switch to Android
switch to Windows switch to pee pee in
my poopoo my ipod does this frickin
genius factory thing I remember this I
think I you said this when I was a noob
Apple a pollutant noob Apple user long
ago long barely remember it where it
forgets which artwork goes with which
album and makes guesses that's awesome
because it's pretty sure I won't notice
mmm yes you want this you want this
picture with this what song is that five
nights of Freddy's a remix or something
scooter app right before the app crashed
behold the writable cyclone I'm pretty
certain that's what happened this a
tornado just blew and sucked in all the
scooters and this was the visual
representation before everyone just went
down I am this unpopular - - Wow I'm so
popular I have - two friends how many
friends do you have - five ah damn it
what does that mean that you had two
friends and you lost them and now you
have - two friends that's so sad another
apple let me just point out I'm not
saying anything else but another Apple
SMAP Oh Oh God okay fine here's a
Windows one thank you windows very cool
that's right the windows stuff is just
epic he made the cute little smiley face
like elgu I'll never do that again I'm
so sorry okay I mean Japan I think it's
allowed oh it's another Japan one BBC
how to be polite and show respect this
is good it's all about the respect in
Japan but really it you shouldn't be in
the old days of feudal Japan a samurai
warrior would shout you are trying to
view Flash content but you have no Flash
plugin installed oh my god that is so
polite
Thank You BBC that's very cool I'll try
it
someone hands me back my change
you are trying to be a flash content but
you have no Flash plugin installed oh
how old are you 21 user already existed
damn it
better luck next year gamer why do they
always want to know my age so relatable
right for real why I always put the
highest age like I'm hundred and I think
I'm YouTube I'm like hundred and twenty
years or something I'm pretty sure
everyone knows this but I always picked
the highest one and and sometimes it's
really embarrassing because they'll come
back and correct me be like you're not
hundred and twenty years old
your name isn't flippy flippin Stein
come on my raspberry pie sense hat died
today what is that I know what a
raspberry pie is this is his last
message to pay respect my god that's
like saying rest in peace to yourself
when you die I want to win the first
real burial that someone's gonna put an
F on you know it's gonna happen you know
someone who requested it that's in the
chat boys you know I just want the
melons right
oh this went viral I remember this I
think my uber driver is in trouble you
get high I'm on my way
the texts make it so much funnier I
didn't know they had a text it oh my god
yes Google that's exactly how bridges
work basil areas you know someone had to
code that to fix that you never think
about so many details like some
algorithm that detects the bridges and
then doesn't I don't know I don't know
it's pretty cool if you think about it
I've seen the chat for Ohio guys slash
Ohio will be eliminated gone but not
forgotten my boy humid stuck on 69 quiz
complete final score 99.99 1999 in a
night correct answer questions 19 out of
19 would you like to try again
maybe you should go for 100%
maybe try again try a little harder
trying to rotate 90 degrees don't you
just type 90 oh my god that's so
annoying hundred ninety so what is
actually sad your PC reckon where did he
go come back please
oh god everyone leaves me imagine being
such a loser that your computer leaves
you F's in the chat okay okay okay okay
let's get some locations in the chat
gamers I'm so sick of all that quote
PewDiePie memes god damn the past four
days it just never stops
oh wow the download is freaking me that
download is freaking me stop
I remember this actually happening back
in the day a lot when when loading
screens were actually really freaking
slow oh wait they still are this is so
sad my AVG bugged out and I think you're
in danger my software became self-aware
you're in danger Felix these files
they're not good this is a big problem
hey Siri what is 68 in German 68 68
Wow Siri thank you so much I gotta try
that hey Google what's 68 in German
Achtung sexy no I prefer 68 I'm gonna go
with serious translation Thank You
Google not epic what is this
cool cool sign cool sign it's a cool
side I don't know what to tell you it's
a cool side
very cool side the
oh gee software Gore wild missingno
appeared I know there's a story behind
this Pokemon for you for your Zoomer so
you wouldn't understand but there was
this epic hidden Pokemon that you could
find I think it was a glitch it's like a
Pokemon that wasn't added to the game
but it was super overpowered as well if
you can't caught it but he's clearly
missing number that didn't register for
me as a kid I was like oh my god missing
you know I think I'm connected to
speedtest Australian service mm-hmm
that's funny it's upside down it's also
married so that make your no sense
remind me to get washing tablets on
Mazda what do you want to be reminded
remind me to get washing tablets when
I'm at a star sorry when do you want to
be reminded when I'm at as that sorry I
still didn't get that just say what time
you want your reminder when I'm at Asda
remind me at 6:30
what's the reminder you you will send
this reminder at 6:00 there this buddy
it's my forehead this entire video
that's awesome I'm not so worried about
a just yet hate Windows 10 search yes it
sucks game DVR no game search and it is
right there all the time I search for
stuff it doesn't appear it's so annoying
the fine pen what's the lovely stroke
with a fine pen oof I'm making my
computer bleed with every stroke Wow
thank you the fine pen is my favorite
brush my TV froze so did this internet
player come on oh my god giggity giggity
goo hey that was a Family Guy reference
that I almost didn't want to commit to
oh my lord why is it on the genitals
[Laughter]
[Music]
seven deadly sins
nice Google well done she says that's
awful what's the cost of a train ticket
from Sydney to Brisbane
the answers 28.8 quadrillion kilometer
you his dollars squared wow that's a lot
of cash
what Siri oh I remember this yeah this
is a glitch too everyone was freaking
out about like oh god people are gonna
do it to me oh no was it on Twitter I
don't remember
confirm order here your game how does
that happen
yo gay my internet is faster than yours
yeah I'll guarantee it try making videos
on a frickin pocket Wi-Fi god this is so
hot I'm surprised it's still working
it's got lower battery even though it's
in charge Jesus it's been charged all
night oh my god Wow
I want that internet speed that's what I
want that's what I deserve come on
great your heart rate is zero zero
fantastic well done you have achieved
meditation Oh Medical watching the
office of my computer and every now and
then the image glitch is up but this is
the most horrifying thing I've ever seen
Michael Scott has never seen such BS
before this is this like nightmare feel
a lot of it this is super creepy you're
gonna meet the love of your life at
11:10 65 damn it I was so close there's
my meal when I was a kid I was like but
after 12 is it 1 or 0 12 is zero
Oh who know my brain after 12 is 1 zero
Sarah comes after they are what time is
zero zero zero
I remember this there was a warning in
Hawaii it was like a year ago they
accidentally set off the alarm for a
missile line layer and this was the
screen the ballistic missile alert the
operator clicked on Packham and he's
supposed to click the drill one good
good UI your first name doesn't comply
with our Community Guidelines we don't
take kindly to know James around here if
you're named James leave
bye-bye this is the same problem we have
in Sweden when we're trying to write the
end which means solute which means slot
obviously you tell someone to stop
something slip slip slip that and it
just censored in a line it's like Dennis
stop up so annoying Swedish problems I
yesterday I told Sarah to remind me to
die today and her crustash sent me this
she did
Siri you cold-hearted son of a okay bye
please die these files cannot be open
your internet security sitting prevented
the files from being open closed windows
security your inner security safe I
can't even open a program to screenshot
this everything is good everything is
fine
this is the computer version of this is
fine meme this is fine everything is
good good oh my god this video contains
content from Verizon Wireless TV who has
blocked it on copyright grounds thank
you Verizon very cool it was number one
I'm trending - this is such a perfect
example of why the system is so stupid
because it claims first and ask
questions later
literally the White House a few days ago
uploaded a meme of Nickelback and I got
copyrighted I don't think my internet
likes me anymore I'm trying to just pull
up a simple image scientists show it for
me please
time to learn Japanese Oh
bridges that's the hard thing that
apparently well done well done very cool
flight simulator oh my god it's a weird
that I know what this image is my school
cafeterias are me what do you identify
as male correct answer female try again
next time I'm not a robot try again next
damn robots has anyone ever failed at
one of those hey mom look at me run
there it is
Pepsi man another amazing copyright
system in place here your own song got
copyrighted thank you
damn this suffering infuriates me which
of these numbers is closest to math
processing error question mark math
processing error or math processing
error I'm gonna go with 0.05 I don't
know bye you guys
oh I remember this what game is this
it's like a baseball game the most
horrifying moment in video game you say
wow how does that happen
he's so bad nightmares oh oh
that makes me sick Texas enter a valid
state please
stupid Texas try another state like Ohio
you have tried you have tried you have
tried you have a tried you haven't tried
thank you computer you have tried oh god
none of the anime nothing is safe now
the anime wife's Oh God
ready to actually broke oh god is this a
thing oh god it's didn't ready
hello this is the most ironic thing I've
ever seen are you kidding me
I've never seen this glitch up are you
kidding me are you joking
what from browsing reddit well I'll take
your hands Google I understand it's time
to end this video if you guys enjoyed
feel free to smash like and subscribe
subscribe and be a gamer if you want to
support the channel I would appreciate
it check out represent calm sighs
PewDiePie we have some epic March keeps
you haven't seen it that's it what you
haven't tried to Bruce emulator at
citizen e after 50 million out troops by
etch down just down it's still relevant
just